Indiana Jones is one of those things
where you might as well do it because
you cannot Escape it especially the
music is is a constant thing in your
life I I did this a tribute for John
Williams and I and they played me on
with the theme from Indiana Jones
and I said I cannot uh escape this
goddamn music
I said I and this is true I hear it in
the elevator the last time I was uh
lightly sedated and rolled in for a
colonoscopy
they were playing it on the speaker
[Applause]
[Music]
and now let's talk tonight with Harrison
and Ryan's movie it is the much awaited
Blade Runner 2049 it opens on the 5th of
October and I mean the expectation the
hopes for this or how it really Scott's
involved Harrison you were involved but
presumably this isn't the first time I'm
not just involved
[Applause]
okay my question is this so it must have
been mentions of a sequel between it was
1982 wasn't it when it came out so
between then and now so why now why not
before
I guess because Ryan wasn't available
[Music]
for 30 years but they were waiting for
me to grow up
but they decided to have to go ahead
anyway
finally I came up with a good uh with
the story and I read it I thought it was
awesome I thought it was great and I as
I read it I read about the character
that
Ryan Ryan that's right
came to play and I said and I with great
enthusiasm I called up the producers and
I said this is great I can't wait to
hear blah blah blah and uh what a great
part why don't we see if we can get um
Ryan
Gosling yeah and they said oh uh I don't
know
dazzling Brian
you got that on tape Ryan
and I said why don't this is a great
part for uh Ryan Gosling
everything
[Applause]
and they said we've been talking to him
for months now wait a second they'd only
been talking to me for weeks
so they probably would have gone ahead
without me no no no that's what I said
yeah
because things do take preparation like
fights take preparation and they take a
lot of preparation now Ryan is it true
that Harrison bills there we go
it actually feels wrong you you were
underprepared for the one no
I know you're refer I know you're yes
just say it usually
will he punch you yeah yeah that's right
well he punched you
I can't say friendship
but you weren't meant to punch him
right oh I misread the script
he stepped on my foot for Christ's sake
we were doing a scene in lights and
flashing strobe lights uh walking he's
walking backward I was walking forward
the camera was handheld you you know you
have to make the punch look like it's
intended but uh
I hit him
one out of a hundred times right now
yeah I should be lucky I didn't get hit
more so that's the theme of this I
apologize it's not just the punch though
I mean I think it's like a Harrison Ford
punches a different animal altogether I
was not it was not a good punch I just I
I'll be the judge of that okay
I apologize I went to his dressing room
with uh his palatial motorhome with a
bottle of Scotch in hand
you know lovely just cracked the top
poured him a drink gave him a drink says
you know it's uh he said I'm kind of
busy now
yeah and I went back to my trailer with
the rest of the bottle
had the intention to leave it but
my hand hurt
I needed some medicine actually we do
have there's a still I think this is the
actual moment when you punched Brian for
real
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
because now because Ryan you were also a
young entrepreneur weren't you
I wouldn't say that no
her father what did he eat he wanted you
to sell was it cellophane he wanted to
do so
my parents Came Upon a truck of
cellophane somehow
it's not to ask too many questions
I just suddenly there was a basement
filled with cellophane and uh
they encouraged me to go to school and
see if I could sell it to my teachers or
put a few in my backpack and try and
Hawk them at recess you know
convince kids that they might be a good
uh stocking stuffers for their parents
cellophane
how did it go
what do you mean it was to use this
elephant I know the name but I don't
know what you do with it you know you
wrap sandwiches in it it keeps things
fresh oh okay
I'm sorry no no no it was an important
question yeah
at Harrison famously you worked as a as
a carpenter in your early life but you
studied woodwork with your father but he
he wasn't that good
my dad was in advertising and he he
liked to to make things and uh we were
down in the in the basement
working on building a table and he cut
off his finger
[Music]
and uh why he lost me
he's laughing
yeah it's quite funny when it sold like
that
it wasn't funny uh
at the time I thought
I was 16 years old I I had
not much experience with this but I I I
wrapped my hand my dad's hand up and I
got him upstairs to the then I called
the police and I and then I ran
downstairs and I picked up the finger
and I put it in the kleenex and this is
a long time ago so when I got to the
emergency Ward I said
um and here's my dad's anyone
because that was a while ago and they
didn't really even think about trying to
attach if I know you had some cellophane
yeah
thank you
who knew yeah then was did he just have
no finger well I had no finger here he
cut off about this much of this finger
why are you pointing that at me
but he but he went uh but he cut about
halfway through this finger as well
and but they they were able to save that
but my father used to admonish me
sometimes and he would point at me
but he would be pointing at me but his
finger was going like that so I would
always look
really made him mad
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign